curbside bus came on with a store on the
East Coast Pittsburgh Atlanta now Texas
really 44 the like city's something to
celebrate indeed the curbside bus
industry has grown an exceptionally
rapid rate but the safety regime has
failed to keep pace the state is putting
the brakes on Fung Wah bus routing
serious safety problems across its
entire fleet so you really want to
encourage bus travel and the temptation
governments I think is we got to be able
to control this we got to know what's
happening 100 years ago the very first
American bus conference started picking
up passengers on Main streets all across
America it was remarkably easy to break
into the business simply buy or lease a
motor coach and then start doing regular
pickups on a street corner gasoline
gasoline in 1914 a former diamond
driller named Carl Eric Wickman started
a bus service running out of hitting
Minnesota the company would eventually
adopt a new name greyhounds like you
while the ride Nana Greyhound bus with
me and all the scenery and comfort was
it such a car
take the bus and leave the driving to us
integrate greyhound expanded across the
country by the end of World War two the
bus industry was on track to provide a
billion passenger trips per year
compared to cars buses were cheaper more
environmentally friendly and much safer
but Greyhound lasted so many years as
America's pre-eminent bus company for
all the wrong reasons
starting in the 1920s buses were highly
regulated the government set fares and
schedules and made it illegal for other
bus companies to compete with Greyhound
on many of its routes
this set the stage for the industry's
remarkable decline protected from
competition Greyhound and other bus
companies became indifferent to the
changing tastes of their customers
Americans relocated to the suburbs car
and air travel exploded in popularity
after world war ii must travel declined
by half in just a decade fast forward
all the way to 1982 with motor coach
trouble still in decline President
Reagan signed a bill that deregulated
the bus industry clearing the way for
new companies to get into the business
and start fighting to win back
passengers
deregulation didn't immediately send the
industry into overdrive that took
another 15 years when a group of
immigrants from the Fujian Province
China reinvented the bus industry right
here in the streets in New York City's
Chinatown that kicked off a stunning
comeback for the bus gasoline gasoline
these entrepreneurs brought the industry
back to its roots for picking up
passengers right off the street instead
of at a traditional station once again
pretty much all you needed to start a
company was a bus
Joseph Shui Terman who's a professor at
DePaul University studies the bus
industry we haven't seen anything like
this really sensible for World War two
to have a new mode particularly serving
downtown to downtown the Chinatown
companies had figured out a way to win
over customers that eluded Greyhound for
decades charge really low prices what
made you choose the bus it's cheap
because it's cheaper and we tried
Airlines is like three times so you just
came here for a shopping trip yes and
you decided to take the bus because it
was cheap
yes cheap very cheap the rise of
portable technologies has also been a
boon for the bus people simply bring
their lives with them and the last thing
I want to do in many cases be stuck
behind a wheel what are you gonna do for
four hours watch movies you could plug
your phone in charge up your phone work
on my DJ equipment on my laptop that's
about it competition from Chinatown was
even good for Greyhound which we learned
how to fight for customers boy now the
industry is cracked wide open and
greyhounds just trying to hang on to get
its piece of the action and some of the
growth and so we're seeing a new
greyhound now the company has gone to
almost comical lengths to imitate the
Chinatown bus
Here I am in Chinatown in front of what
may look like a real mom-and-pop
independent Chinese bus service but this
is yo bus and yo bus is actually owned
by Greyhound Greyhound started yo bus in
partnership with Peter Pan Bus Lines the
two companies first joined forces to
create yet another Chinatown imitator
bolt bus how was your trip how was your
trip it was good how was your trip what
did you do on your trip sleep today
busing is the fastest-growing form of
intercity transit in the United States
however once again government is
threatening to regulate away its dynamic
nature history is repeating itself in
May 2012 the federal Department of
Transportation shut down 26 bus
companies in a single day on safety
grounds and since then it has forced an
additional 15 closures the irony is that
it's profoundly safer to ride in a bus
than it is to drive it's like driving in
an armored vehicle you're driving in a
car where there are even head-on
collisions and most of the bus has a
high chance of surviving so you really
want to encourage bus travel and the
temptation governments I think is we got
to be able to control this we got to
know what's happening over regulating
bus lines perversely makes passengers
less safe since all the shutdowns ticket
prices have spiked considerably this
means fewer travelers will be enticed to
take the bus and leave their cars at
home making them far more likely to die
on the highway
riders seem to understand intuitively
just how safe bus travel is are you at
all concerned about safety or no
yes hey yes sir buses are safe you can
send it all about safety no I'm not
really people don't usually message me
too much I guess
yeah what about the safety of the buses
uh no I've never had a problem with any
other bus I never even thought about it
the state is putting the brakes on Fung
Wah bus
safety problems across its entire fleet
when the government forced the bus
company from wah to shut down in March
of 2013 it was a major blow to the
Chinatown bus industry the company rose
to prominence a decade ago for charging
just $10 to go between Boston and the
Big Apple in those cities for a while
was a household name The New Yorker
magazine even produced an ironic tribute
to the company after it was forced to
close its doors fun one the bus of the
crowd you've been shut down by London
gonna longer
edie this is the letter the state is
sending to federal regulators accusing
Fung Wah of putting its drivers
passengers and everyone on the road at
risk Fung Wah was logging almost three
million miles on the road every year and
in over a decade of service it never
once had a fatal crash so why then did
the government shut it down in February
2013 government bus inspectors found
that multiple Fung Wah buses had cracks
in their frames what these inspectors
didn't know is that all tour buses have
frame cracks and they generally don't
pose a safety risk to passengers that's
because tour buses are fabricated in one
piece so the structures are extremely
sturdy the commercial vehicle safety
Alliance which sets official inspection
guidelines for buses has acknowledged
the bus inspectors have been
overreacting to frame cracks in buses
like those owned by Fung Wah currently
the organization is rewriting its
inspection guidelines in order to
alleviate some of the misdiagnosed
violations here in new york city the
busing industry is facing another threat
that has nothing to do with safety a new
state law in new york requires the bus
companies get a special permit from the
city before they can start operating on
the streets you start making
organizations get permits suddenly now
we have taken a product and applying it
to a part of the civil sector that was
never intended to be regulated I'm
optimistic about the big players they
know how to play the game they have
lawyers but I do worry about the small
campus run bus operation subjecting
yourself to public hearings and things
can create all kind of uncertainties and
that's where we're just it's a dangerous
game to require this for something as as
simple as an over-the-road bus service
the government isn't just driving up the
cost of bus travel it is also pouring
taxpayer money into high-speed train
lines and light rail projects no matter
how expensive or impractical they are
nevertheless American travelers are
increasingly choosing to take the bus
because it is cheap safe good for the
environment convenient and it gets them
exactly where they need to go for recent
TV I'm Naomi Rockwell
fred is Debray
you